here are some things no one tells you
happens once you get engaged number one
you won't always be surprised by your
proposal couples have many conversations
about marriage before the proposal even
happens so you'll probably see it coming
girl even saying the word fiance is so
weird
my fiancee is my fiance I mean you try
it disagreements will feel heavier like
times ten there'll be so many
frustrations but I think the most
important thing is to listen to your
partner and to discuss your frustrations
if you are not used to wearing jewelry
every day you will 100 forget to wear
your ring
the urge to elope is real we already
know how expensive weddings are but then
we have some more costs come up like the
weddings license fee or the wedding cake
tasting fee child please lastly not
everyone's gonna be happy for you I mean
everyone has their Rhyme or Reason for
why not but the most important thing is
for you to focus on you and your new
fiance